bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes en la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
comenzamos
bolivia tiene en el salar de uyuni
alrededor del 21 por ciento del litio
metálico del mundo que demanda la
industria automotriz para producir las
baterías de autos eléctricos se trata de
los mayores yacimientos registrados del
planeta sin embargo después de 13 años
con un proyecto estatal bolivia aún no
ha logrado dar el salto para convertirse
en el mayor proveedor del sector como
pretende la politización las carencias
científicas y financieras y las disputas
regionales
configuran un escenario de laberinto
para impulsar el desarrollo del metal la
empresa estatal de litio ya hizo
inversiones millonarias para desarrollar
tecnología propia sin conseguir
resultados importantes y últimamente ha
invitado a 9 empresas transnacionales
para recibir propuestas de soluciones
para la extracción nos acompaña hoy
javier aliaga quien junto a mary vacas
realizó este reportaje hola javier
comienzo preguntándole la producción de
litio de bolivia todavía es baja
comparada con la guerra y chile porque
se dice que bolivia llega tarde al
mercado grande de litio
con herminia gracias por la invitación
de este espacio cuando hablamos de una
baja producción de litio en bolivia nos
estamos refiriendo sobre todo a la
producción de una planta piloto que este
año llegaría en el mejor de los casos
hasta unas 750 toneladas cuando
argentina por ejemplo produce más de 33
mil y tiene más de 120.000 oliver
también quiere participar de ir al
mercado de litio y espera inaugurar el
próximo año una planta industrial para
producir como 15 mil toneladas no
obstante los analistas creen que bolivia
llega tarde porque los países vecinos
llevan muchos años desde el mercado
tiene mucha experiencia y además los
analistas creen que dentro de una década
lo que va a dominar el mercado de litio
es el litio reciclado es decir que la
producción de los hablar es quizás ya no
sea muy competitiva en términos de
precio después de ese periodo
si javier y le pregunto también cuál es
la importancia de que los sectores
sociales las comunidades y la sociedad
misma del salar de uyuni sean
consultadas sobre el desarrollo del
litio ahora que hay un cambio desde la
estrategia estatal y nacionalista hacia
la participación de varias empresas
privadas extranjeras
ese es un tema muy muy sensible en
bolivia herminia porque históricamente
los sectores sociales siempre tienen
muchas expectativas sobre la explotación
de recursos naturales y en este caso del
vídeo hasta ven con una cierta esperanza
milagrosa de que de 'el inmediatos
recursos para poder beneficiarse del
desarrollo entonces el gobierno está
consciente de que debe consultar a las
comunidades a los municipios de
alrededor del salar pero las comunidades
no tienen una consulta en las que sólo
se les dé información sino que también
quieren aportar para participar con las
propuestas de esta forma es todavía
incierto qué va a pasar cuando las
empresas extranjeras les den hasta lar
con las comunidades porque las
comunidades van a emitir sus sus
criterios van a opinar políticamente y
técnicamente como siempre han hecho
sí muchas graciasjavier ahora veamos el
reportaje
[Música]
desde la ciudad boliviana de cochabamba
el empresario josé carlos márquez
trabaja para que bolivia sea una
protagonista de la transición mundial
hacia la electromovilidad urbana con la
fabricación de pequeños coches
eléctricos que son económicos y
funcionan con baterías de litio muchas
veces como contamina
este
bueno este es el auto que yo tengo es un
de tres que es de tres mil watts
márquez es el signo de quantum motors
que en tres años ha producido cerca de
400 vehículos para bolivia perú paraguay
y el salvador también los está
fabricando en méjico donde estarán a la
venta antes de fin de año
mientras vendía
y está maquinando para ponerle el
silicón
después
de 44 mil watts
estos vehículos pesan 350 kilos cuestan
en bolivia entre 6.000 y 8.000 dólares y
rinden 100 kilómetros tras una carga de
6 horas el empresario ve en
latinoamérica una oportunidad para estos
coches
la velocidad promedio es de 13
kilómetros por hora entonces nuestros
autos si bien llegan a 50 60 kilómetros
por hora pero se mueven muy bien en
velocidades bajas por el tamaño que
tienen y también por
el desempeño que tienen que el tamaño
del motor y el peso entonces son autos
muy eficientes como para este mercado la
empresa también ha inaugurado la primera
fábrica de bolivia para ensamblar
baterías de litio para sus autos y el
mercado externo
creo que quantum y bolivia pueden estar
a la vanguardia de lo que se viene de
todo el mundo que es el cambio de matriz
energética que tanto se necesita la
apuesta ha sido celebrada por el mundo
empresarial el gobierno la oposición los
diplomáticos y los ciudadanos que con
los coches eléctricos apoyan la
reducción de la contaminación del aire
más del 90% de la contaminación del aire
contaban con partículas sólidas tóxicas
sale del escape de los
entonces se ha convertido en un motivo
apoyo
y contribución a mejorar la calidad del
aire a través de la electromovilidad
desde su fundación la firma ha invertido
5 millones de dólares en un país sin
tradición tecnológica sus logros han
sido resonantes pero es paradójico que
importe celdas de litio de china para
ensamblar las baterías ya que bolivia
tiene el mayor yacimiento mundial de
este mineral en el salar de uyuni aunque
está desaprovechado este gigante
desierto blanco tiene una superficie de
10 mil 500 kilómetros cuadrados casi el
tamaño de qatar el salar contiene 21
millones de toneladas métricas de litio
que de explotarse se convertirían en un
gran tesoro ya que su precio se ha
disparado hasta los 70 mil dólares por
tonelada
en esta zona la mitad de los habitantes
vive en la pobreza muchos trabajan en el
turismo y con las artesanías de sal como
en el caso de nicodemo change
cómico es un famoso escultor en sal con
una amoladora ha creado una llama un
búho y la torre eiffel para venderlas en
la feria del pueblo
esta es la torre de parís que hemos
hecho es toda la mañana pero este este
bloque es tipo mármol es pero sal para
nicodemo el salar es un regalo divino
yo vivo de la sal es una materia prima y
donde quien nosotros gracias a dios
vivimos en colchones y significa la sal
para mí es una bendición de dios amigos
chambi es optimista y confía que algún
día la explotación del litio mejorará la
vida de la región no hay que ser
pesimista no hay un y un día va a
despertar ahorita está durmiendo y un y
porque un elefante blanco que tenemos
dormido en la puerta del salar
la situación económica se ha agravado
porque la pandemia redujo el número de
turistas antes llegaban 400 vehículos
diarios al salar ahora 40 en el mejor
día
el arte de nicodemo no se limita a las
artesanías sino que también ha ayudado a
construir hoteles de sal lujosos no
obstante él sigue siendo una persona muy
sencilla que también trabaja como guía
turístico
este paisaje cinematográfico es
magnético para los visitantes de día
juegan a perpetuar su visita con
fotografías en perspectiva cerca de la
noche el crepúsculo y sus reflejos en el
salar se combinan en un cuadro de
ensueño
alrededor de estos parajes casi lunares
viven los indígenas de la nación lípez
cuyos casi que es narciso bartolomé y et
son muralla defienden que el salar es
parte del territorio ancestral
comunitario y se quejan de que son
ignorados por el gobierno cuando
plantean reclamos sobre el litio
anteriormente nuestro antepasados nos
han dejado ya con miedo territorio
y más que todo ahora pedimos al gobierno
que nos reconozca en nuestro
nuestro testimonio y vamos a hacer
nuestros respectivos representaciones lo
que nosotros siempre queremos es que se
nos consulte para poder dar unos buenos
criterios y poderlo hacerlo algo sólido
esto de la exportación de nuestro de
nuestro litio que va a generar
movimiento económico no para nosotros
para todos estas gigantes piscinas
industriales de evaporación de salmueras
para obtener litio pertenecen a la
empresa estatal yacimientos bolivianos
de litio e iu lv las piscinas no han
dado los resultados esperados y son
objeto de críticas
así pues no va a dar resultados no mucho
más
la forma más primitiva de hacer limpios
esto por las promesas incumplidas las
críticas contra el proyecto estatal de
litio aumentan en el pueblo de colcha k
que se denomina a sí mismo la capital
del litio boliviano y donde los caciques
han reunido a un grupo de personas para
que sean escuchadas o sea aparentemente
en estos 11 años se ha hecho una digamos
un trabajo de pruebas han hecho las
piscinas
que no han tenido resultados bien
clarito nos han dibujado que va a ver
que él
los automóviles por ejemplo van con el
litio va a funcionar que vamos a tener
baterías baterías de litio hasta ahorita
no hay nada
los vecinos de colcha k también están
preocupados por una reducción de las
reservas de agua dulces subterráneas y
que va a ser realmente en el futuro o
sea que nosotros vamos a tener que
e importar agua comprar agua que va a
ser de nuestra generación futura
generación
vertientes naturales alimentan la
represa cercana a colcha acá pero los
comunarios temen que las aguas sean
mermadas o contaminadas con la sal
cuando se ponga en marcha la nueva
tecnología de la extracción directa de
litio alternativa a las piscinas de
evaporación solar
el cacique muraña quiso llevar las
quejas de la comunidad al gobierno pero
dice que no ha sido escuchado y tampoco
se le ha permitido visitar las
instalaciones de las plantas de iu lv
protegidas por el ejército
nosotros queremos ser parte pero que no
nos ignore las autoridades conocen la
importancia de la armonía con las
comunidades del salar y se han reunido
con otros grupos sociales las tensiones
sobre litio son latentes en 2019 una ola
de protestas obligó a evo morales- a
rescindir un contrato de
industrialización de litio con la
alemana así systems
la empresa estatal de litio y lb celebró
cinco años de vida en abril pasado
cuando mostraron lo producido en sus
fábricas piloto baterías para
ordenadores cargadores portátiles y unas
cuantas baterías para quantum probadas
en este prototipo de coche eléctrico el
proyecto de litio nació en 2008 con el
objetivo principal de hacer baterías
para autos de alta potencia y el ex
presidente evo morales quería socios
para hacer coches eléctricos en uyuni
pero esos objetivos no fueron alcanzados
estamos empezando con los cuatro packs
posteriormente
de 6 más ya tenemos un total de 10 y
posiblemente a seguir sumando
paulatinamente la cantidad de plata
las cuatro baterías de prueba fueron
entregadas al ejecutivo de quantum en el
mismo acto del aniversario como una
muestra de que el estado también puede
fabricar baterías para coches aunque de
forma piloto
los analistas calculan que el estado ha
invertido
585 millones de dólares desde el 2012 de
los más de 1200 millones de dólares
aprobados para el proyecto con esos
fondos se construyeron varias plantas en
el salar que no nos permitieron visitar
pese a las gestiones realizadas
para mostrar las grandes instalaciones
que ha montado en uyuni el gobierno nos
ha facilitado unas imágenes de archivo
tras varios años de trabajo e inversión
ahora el gobierno cambiará la estrategia
para la explotación del litio
buscando las mejores alternativas
el estado boliviano que inicialmente
había apostado por un enfoque
nacionalista para explotar el litio
ahora se asociará o contratar a varias
empresas que tienen la nueva tecnología
para obtener el metal que demanda la
electromovilidad esto es algo
transparente no es una licitación es una
convocatoria que presenten resultados de
sus patentes con salmueras específicas
en cada uno de los salares las empresas
clasificadas son cuatro chinas una
estadounidense y una rusa el gobierno no
quiere atarse a una sola empresa y
prefiere tener varias opciones para hoy
uni y los salares más pequeños de
coipasa y pastos grandes sin embargo el
investigador del litio gonzalo mondaca
cree que el cambio de tecnología llega
con retraso dice que estamos tarde y
nosotros también lo hemos afirmado que
estamos tarde porque
los cuestionamientos al sistema al
método de explotación
evaporítico que se implementó en en
uyuni ya estaban planteados en el 2014
ya desde esa época podían haberse tomado
medidas para hacer un cambio en
tecnología según mondaca bolivia aún
debe certificar sus yacimientos de litio
como reservas comerciales y repensar su
objetivo de hacer baterías de litio para
coches de alta potencia si tienes que
importar la mayor parte de los insumos
desde el asia para producir aquí una
batería que después tienes que llevar la
otra vez al asia para venderla porque
ahí está el mercado principal entonces
no es rentable con las decisiones que
tome bolivia intentará acelerar el paso
para convertirse en un actor fuerte en
el mercado de litio dominado actualmente
por australia chile y argentina- no
obstante según muchos estudios la
ventana de oportunidades es corta y el
tiempo apremia
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]